[Musica]
buonasera a tutti grazie mille grazie
per l'invito sono contento di essere
stasera qui alla stazione tiburtina
vorrei ringraziare riccardo luna che mi
ha invitato e soprattutto perché ha
insistito perché confesso che all'inizio
non gli effetti non sapevo se potessi
essere il un invitato ideale per il test
perché non pensavo di avere cose molto
interessanti da dire poi in realtà
riccardo mi ha tranquillizzato mi ha
detto guardano tranquillo comunque un
contesto in cui ti troverai bene perché
comunque parleremo in questa sede di
innovazione e tecnologia nella cura
della frammentazione della personalità e
del bipolarismo è quindi trovi allora ti
ringrazio riccardo è per questo invito
che mi ha fatto sicuramente molto
piacere
allora no non è vero e le immagini che
avete visto sono tratte da una da una
serie da una web serie che ho girato più
o meno tre anni fa e che parla di esami
universitari si chiama proprio esami è
stata un'esperienza che per me è stata
molto particolare perché è nata da una
è andata effettivamente da vita vissuta
nel senso che io sono laureato in
giurisprudenza
come potete intuire dalla mia giacca che
porta che un po la nostra uniforme
diciamo di noi abbiamo studiato il
diritto e allora perché mi sono iscritto
a giurisprudenza perché mi sono fidato
di quella frase che viene detta molto
spesso immagino che insomma quasi
sicuramente qualcuno che la studio alla
studiata cioè tutti iscrive a
giurisprudenza perché all'inizio ti
dicono tranquillo iscriviti perché poi
ti si aprono tante porte esata bra e
questo è il gesto che accompagna allora
io si dà il caso che mi sono creato con
95 e le porte immediatamente sono chiuse
tutte quante insieme sono rimaste aperte
solo due porte che effettivamente il
voto di 95 ti permette di solcare la
prima per quanto riguarda le professioni
legali negli studi privati negli studi
legali è quella di che poi ti può
portare ad arrivare a posizioni come il
coffee manager in uno studio legale
il fotocopia account il dominus
supermarket shopper cioè comunque ci
sono delle posizioni importanti per
quanto rigarda invece il settore
pubblico un voto come 95 in
giurisprudenza ti permette di ambire ad
una carica professionale che è
praticamente la persona che mette i
sassi nella bilancia di forum
questo è il ciò qui a cui si può ambire
allora in realtà prima di di laurearmi
ho passato dei bruttissimi quarti d'ora
con i miei esami universitari facendo
gli esami giurisprudenza e a un certo
punto nei periodi d'esami mi rendevo
conto che con gli amici parlavamo solo
di quello cioè sembrava che ognuno
avesse un aneddoto più surreale del
dell'altro che riguardasse proprio esami
ma non solo con i miei colleghi anche
con con amici di tutte quante le altre
facoltà a me sono successe veramente
cose assurde durante gli esami per
esempio una volta mi è successa una cosa
che anche in un che anche in un video
che non so se possiamo vedere adesso se
c'è dovremmo avere una piccola una
piccola testimonianza di di una cosa che
è accaduta ma penso ma se non c'è ve la
racconto sostanzialmente una volta mi è
capitato di fare un esame
eccola qua appunto che può dare luogo ad
un eccesso di domanda oppure ad un
termine a questa che quella che mi ha
chiamato mi guarda che si nemici sapete
cercava uno strumento di croazia 2012
stampano carne ma che gli eroi di non ho
guardi ci pensi ci pensi ci pensi a
stagione che gli eroi di una volta ho
sostenuto un esame con un assistente che
per tutto il tempo ha guardato le foto
di una su facebook e alla fine ma pure
messo 30 io penso che fosse più per lei
il voto che per me ho sempre avuto
questo sospetto però insomma non ho mai
detto
insomma a soprattutto mai l'ho accettato
volentieri allora
prima di laurearmi cosa ho deciso di
fare avevo molta voglia di raccontare
l'università italiana ma non come come
veniva raccontata in televisione o al
cinema sempre in questa maniera molto
stereotipata con gli studenti che si
innamorano fra i banchi io volevo
proprio parlarne da studente cioè volevo
sentire le cose che succedevano davvero
quindi libretti universitari buttati in
faccia assistenti che che ti lasciano in
mezzo all'esame perché devono andare a
mangiare professori che diventano
sottosegretari alla giustizia e lasciano
47 tesisti in mezzo alla strada
volevo raccontare l'università per
quello che veramente era quindi ho
radunato una decina di amici che tutti i
professionisti insomma che già comunque
giravano e ciascuno specializzato nel
proprio ambito
ho scritto dieci sketch ciascuno parlava
di l'esame di una diversa facoltà e
abbiamo girato il tutto nelle aule del
dams una volta che abbiamo finito di
girare ci siamo trovati queste dieci
puntate ci siamo trovati a un bivio
molto importante cioè ci siamo chiesti
cosa fare perché non vendiamo tutto ad
una televisione
allora abbiamo preso contatti abbiamo
contattato una rete che non vi posso
dire quale era e questa rete ci ha
offerto più o meno per queste dieci
puntate circa un'ora di materiale 8 di e
fra le 8 e le 10 mila rupie però 9 euro
lupi e questo più o meno era al cambio
quello quello che ne veniva fuori e non
posso dire il nome della rete la
chiameremo antenna new delhi antenna new
delhi ci offre fra le 8 e le 10 mila
rupie
ci siamo chiesti cosa fare cioè dovremmo
accettare queste 8 10mila rupie e
andarci a mangiare questa pizza a
varanasi una sera tutti insieme
sicuramente l'offerta era allettante che
poi penso lo facciano anche bene la
pizza varanasi però abbiamo pensato se
noi accettiamo questa offerta cosa
perdiamo la libertà di pubblicare i
nostri contributi quando vogliamo
gratuitamente e per tutti a qualsiasi
ora del giorno e della notte su internet
perché purtroppo con antenna new delhi
magari saremmo finiti non so al lunedì
sera alle 23 45 e poi magari saremmo
stati caricati sul portale online di
antenna new delhi antenna new delhi
punto tv che
non so se vi ricordate ma fino a qualche
anno fa i portali online delle
televisioni erano fatti apposta per non
essere fruibile già era tipo un dispetto
che ti facevano avevano messo il
buffering al centro del palinsesto cioè
il buffering era il prodotto di punta
delle dei portali online delle
televisioni quindi che cosa abbiamo
pensato allora va beh mettiamo tutto su
internet cioè mettiamo tutto su internet
tutto su youtube e vediamo che cosa
succede
la prima puntata è stata caricata il 24
gennaio del 2014 e subito dopo
dopo due giorni aveva già attivo 100.000
visualizzazioni che un numero molto alto
anche perché poi noi non avevamo alcuna
strategia di marketing di eni non
avevamo fatto pubblicità non avevamo
semplicemente caricato un video su
youtube e e basta
una cosa che mi colpì molto dal primo
giorno era che sotto i commenti di
facebook io leggevo nel video caricato
su facebook leggevo questo tipo di
commenti che ridere questi siamo noi
lunedì questo succede a noi lunedì
vedrai che questo succede a noi lunedì e
io mi chiedevo che cosa succede a roma
in italia lunedì che abbia a che fare
con me ridotto nello stato in cui ero
nel nella puntata di medicina che
abbiamo già la dovremo anche avere un
reperto fotografico penso che potrebbe
accompagnare cosa accade lunedì in
italia che a che fare con me con questa
bella parrucchetti allora qualche giorno
dopo mi scrive un mio amico mi dice
guarda devi sapere che l'altro giorno al
sant'andrea a roma c'è stata l'esame di
gastroenterologia che per coincidenza
era lo stesso esame che avevo
rappresentato nella prima con tana di
medicina e tutta la facoltà ha condiviso
e visto il tuo video tra l'altro mazza
quanto sei brutto con quella parrucca
quindi io immediatamente ho capito che
quel meccanismo che può insomma secondo
me anzi devo dire cioè poi non gli ho
mai risposto lei dovevo rispondere
peggio perché vede manco male
no però insomma cosa ho capito che
immediatamente avrebbe funzionato molto
bene quel meccanismo di identificazione
per cui uno studente che frequentava una
certa facoltà avrebbe volentieri rivisto
la puntata e l'avrebbe condivisa con
tutti i suoi amici
a quel punto che cosa è successo noi
siamo andate avanti sono sono uscite
tante altre puntate è una cosa che mi
stupisce sempre molto e che sono molto
contento di essere riuscito a fare su
internet
qualcosa che non avrei potuto fare
altrove cioè in televisione perché
probabilmente non nessuno si sarebbe
affidato probabilmente sarebbe stato
visto come un prodotto troppo innovativo
nel in quell'ambito la più grande
soddisfazione però è che alla fine esame
in televisione c'è andata e non è andata
affatto su antenna new delhi bensì sulla
prestigiosa rai siamo stati molto
contenti e ringraziamo perché alla fine
la serie è stata comprata da rai4 e per
me la più grande soddisfazione
professionale della mia carriera è stato
vedere il nome di esami la serie su
questo supporto qui sul televideo
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]